- [Instructor] Oneuli Beach
in Maui has black sand.
The sand is made up of ground lava
instead of ground coral and shells.
So let's think about this.
So the way it read isn't
horrible and I actually like
breaking things up into
kind of smaller sentences.
That tends to just be kinda my style.
But it feels a little redundant.
You say Oneuli or Oneuli,
I don't how the right way
to pronounce it, Beach
in Maui has black sand
and then you're saying the
sand is made up of ground lava.
So it does feel like we're
just finished talking
about the sand and then
you say the sand again.
So maybe a kind of a more
elegant way would just to be
kind of refer to this
and maybe not even have another sentence.
So let's look at the other choices.
Oneuli Beach in Maui has black sand,
with the sand being
made up of ground lava.
Yeah that's, you know they're kinda going
in the direction that I'm
implying, but with the sand
being made up, it feels still redundant.
You said sand and then
you're saying sand again.
So the beach in Maui has
black sand, and this sand is.
So once again you're using sand and sand.
It's kinda the same problem
that you did up here.
Sand and then you're immediately
saying the sand again.
Oneuli Beach in Maui has black sand,
which is made up of ground lava
instead of ground coral and shells.
Yeah this one feels nice.
This one feels really good
because you're not being,
you're not repeating the word sand
over and over again unnecessarily.
We know you're talking about sand.
Beach in Maui has black sand, which is,
the second up here before we corrected it,
the second sentence is referring,
is referring, is talking
about this black sand.
So why don't we just say, why
don't we just create a clause
where we say which is
made up of ground lava
instead of coral, instead
of ground coral and shells?
It actually makes a connection in my brain
a little bit clearer.
That okay, what we're
talking about made up
of ground coral, ground lava instead
of ground coral and shells,
they're talking about,
they're talking about this
black sand right over here.
So I definitely like this
last choice the most.